I'm here to prove once and for all that
I am the best mother I mean I am the
best dad of course I play this game four
years ago but now as you guys know I'm a
dad and I'm kind of an expert
yes I look tired don't write it in the
comments I don't want to hear it you
look like he hates
thank you I have G fuel thank you let's
check out how I did back then yeah
how's that even possible I know I know
how that's possible just goes everywhere
it just goes everywhere
no one ever told me that but the signs
were there
surely I was a terrible dad or mother in
this game oh my God
no no ah okay all right we're just gonna
have to go with well I don't think it'd
be difficult to be any worse than that
all right let's check out this game
First Step meet the baby yes such
excitement a new freshborn baby and it
smells so good
thank you
he wants a pacifier all right you want
pacifier I you know what fine there we
go
grabbed it
boom being a daddy's easy
man you spit it out I mean that's okay
I'm a good dad now
and patience is the key of being a good
father
Ephesians is the key to bring the I'm
reliving my
life
what I see
of course I gotta wash it and uh
actually you also have to sterilize it
but I guess uh this game is just not as
good of a Dad or Mom as I am here you go
my child
my sweet precious child oh how patient I
was hooray what is my hand doing all
right next up diaper change or reading
the expert I know exactly first we take
the baby all right that's not how you
hold a newborn baby but
you have to protect its neck it's the
Precious Little Neck you can't have you
don't have neck muscles like that so
strong but down on baby's station using
the diaper change song diaper change
song diaper change song you throw it in
the trash
Bullseye all right diaper change your
song daddy is here so you can't be mad
at me I gotta wipe you from the poopy I
guess
what is happening uh no cleaning fine
just fresh new diaper there we go
what so I've edited that out I am the
best dad oh oh I see it flew away there
it is it's the powder which I don't
think people use anymore because there
was like some controversy I don't know
exactly
um there you go
easy and baron loves the diaper Changers
song There we go easy best mother fish
just I told you I told you you know what
I'm gonna check I bet I struggled on
that one idiot idiot child of the past I
was a child
dispose of it what's step one step two
completely lost what an idiot Tammy what
Timmy what a dumb name of a child Timmy
what see completely useless what an
idiot what a fool all right moving on
dinner yes he's hungry and let me tell
you if I'm patience as a dad baby zero
patience baby minus patience all right
he wants food he wants it now and I'm
like bruh I'm trying to prepare the food
for you you just gotta wait a second bro
chill out Daddy's doing his best uh oh
God no I know how to do this oh that's
got to be starless how did it even get
that dark like I'm such a good dad I'm
gonna give you a pacifier just so you
can soothe yourself while daddy makes
his delicious snack for you it looks
like a laundry detergent I'm pretty sure
this is laundry detergent don't feed
your child laundry detergent Pro Dad
Hank all right one two and then you
gotta adjust it based on the thing the
best would be the mom breast milk but
you know Daddy's gotta make do all right
we put the lid no catch it it fell in
slow motion excellent never Panic as I
died hot water gotta be 80 degrees baby
easy now we just place it down
I'm panicking
all right it's fine Don't Panic it's
already full does that mean I'm good no
I fill it here
I gotta redo everything put it down okay
we're still good Lonnie detergent
never panic
don't panic I got 30 seconds before
Bjorn is about to explode
put it down
thank you there we go okay I think we're
good I think we're good okay remove the
passive Library
sorry bro
sorry bro I got an achievement for that
let's go collection you better like it
that's fine that's I want it now oh I
already prepared it I'm a genius I'm the
best
I told you I bet you old PewDiePie suck
though
Timmy is a demon
[Music]
we've come a long way interrupting this
video I'm sorry but we need real talk
here I mean taking a break for a while
now and I know you've all been wanting
me back and the reason of core node VPN
promo where's the nordvpn promo when is
he coming back has it dropped yet has
the nordvpn promo drop don't worry your
wait is over as everyone knows only the
best dance use nordvpn with a VPN you
can of course browse the internet safely
and securely and get past all those
pesky region blocks okay next time you
try and watch the show and you get
region blocked and you're like ah damn
it now I didn't listen I didn't sign up
to nordvpn.com PewDiePie like PewDiePie
told me I'm a Fool well I told you know
what I'm a dad now I'm just gonna shame
you Shane disappoint no better
nordvpn also has a ton of amazing free
features hooray built-in such as threat
protection for example thread protection
is another layer of security it does a
ton of cool things but it also scans
files for you if you download them a
friend of mine clicked on a file that he
shouldn't and he got all of his accounts
hey we've all been there should I click
on that I don't know I guess I got no
VPN it'll be like ah it's good or nah
you dummy and my friend actually asked
me hey is there any software I can use
that would help this from The View you
should have placed it anyway your mouth
is frothing you're ready and I'm about
to hit you up with the deal okay here it
comes every purchase with a two-year
plan gets a huge think big right now I'm
talking big discount Plus
four month free and
I won't shame you this is only if you
use the link nordvpn.com PewDiePie it's
risk-free trying out 30 day money back
guarantee
that's nordvpn.com thank you for sponsor
this video thank you thank you back to
be dead Hard movie what the [__] is that
aisles and ET that's true baby always
first all right sometimes I eat too I
eat food I eat too
but no baby's gotta eat yeah you gotta
take care of yourself it's important not
to forget yourself uh baby he wants
pacifier boom it's dirty what the [__]
is this place
where am I
oh is that my belly or his belly where's
the Goddamn Gage there we go
watch it
we
oh God I'm hungry here you go my man
let's put a big bread this is actually
very accurate
whatever now my sister Cooks I don't
know how she managed to do it she takes
care of everything if anything she's got
two babies at the house
I'm hungry again uh where's the machine
now we just gotta put it down
I put it down let's go no I'm starving
of course all okay okay
donut
cookie donut
okay please
please don't push it over
okay I think I think we're good I think
we're good
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
I can do this never Panic as a parent I
gotta eat something though or I'll die
lingon berries to the risk oh they're
actually really good Baron sounds like
he's still happy he's not crying
everything is good holy [__] I actually
did it I can't believe it I can't
believe it I'm the best dad I am the
best dad
why no what did I miss
what did I do put it down
put it
[Music]
linger Barry
I got nothing else free I think this is
a restart the stress of this game is
very accurate I'm not gonna lie I don't
know why I'm doing this to myself oh
there were sausages there the whole time
I didn't see them
pescatarian I couldn't all right I think
I did it
I think I did it
there you go my man
a tiny little boy drink well become
strong epic Viking that's right wow so
strong you threw that so high all right
we gotta eat real fast bread bread and
then put this on and I put that on Timmy
Timmy you're gonna love this you're
gonna love it it's empty
don't throw it we don't throw things in
this house
I'm not even gonna wait for your
instructions I'm just gonna prepare
stuff also very accurate whatever time
you have you're gonna make the fullness
out of like me recording this video
right now all right what do you just
want yeah probably a diaper change this
diaper station sucks it's way too high
up but if he falls and there's no cover
he could just roll over what an
irresponsible video game anyway there
you go
oh God he looks psychotic you know this
game is not accurate because you know
every time you change the damn diaper he
decides to go for a second oh what's
that I wasn't done surprise [__] how
bad was I in the past see I haven't even
done the first one yet what an idiot I
didn't think it was possible to hate
babies I hate babies
well I got news for you bro
food poisoning who's got the poisoning
oh I got the poison oh [__] I gotta
where's the toilet there it is
[Laughter]
don't tell Bjorn don't tell Bjorn I can
poop and take care of babies at the same
time
ah
see I don't even need you anymore
useless I wonder how many people
actually knows what I'm talking about I
hope not too many all right baby time
this is really the hardest part just
putting down the bottle here
oh no
I got time I I believe I believe I can
take care of a child before I shoot
myself no I can't I got it I'm sorry
behind I try oh I don't flush oh God
that's disgusting I'm sorry ah there we
go one
what that's there must be a glitch that
has to be a glitch
all right martial is giving him a bath
and he gets upset when we change his
clothes so prizes of Berlin he's asleep
now almost mice is taking care of him
but I thought you know what that's
probably a good time to end it you get
the time that you get and I just wanted
to shoot this video and it's really fun
and I hope I proved Wonder for all that
I am the best there thank you
there we go went from the game Prime
baby real life crying baby it never
stands because I'm the best mom
mine says the best one
[Music]
all right